on peut conclure quelques axes majeurs
d'abord par rapport à à l'événement
déclencheur de ces violence urbaine qui
est le décès du jeune Naël
ananter on a moins de 8 % des euh
condamnés qui font référence à cet
événement pour justifier de leur
comportement dans le cadre des émeut en
second point
euh les contestations enfin que l'on qui
apparaissent à travers
euh les attaques contre les forces de
sécurité ou les destruction de bâtiments
publics ne sont pas revendiqués par les
auteurs des faits
euh c'est quelque chose qui paraît
plutôt euh dans je dirais dans la
pratique habituelle de certains d'entre
eux 3è point euh
la majorité la totalité ou quasi-
totalité des condamnés n'exprime aucune
revendication d'ordre idéologique ou
politique qui soit
susceptible de
motivé une forme de colère et une
expression de la
violence on constate toutefois
que ces actions et quand on voit les
déclarations des mises en cause ces
actions dénotent un rapport euh très
décomplexé des auteurs des faits par
rapport à l'expression de la violence
c'està-dire que ça paraît euh sans
limites sans barrières euh en terme en
terme de valeur et euh y compris
lorsqu'il s'agit d'agression physique à
l'encontre des personnes dépositaires de
l'autorité publique